climate change is actually where we're
going to begin this morning because
president biden has arrived in scotland
hoping to restore america's credibility
and leadership on tackling the problem
he left rome this morning to attend the
u.n climate change conference in glasgow
alongside leaders of other countries
that adopted the 2015 paris agreement
all this comes after the president spent
the weekend in italy at the g20 summit
rija zhang has been traveling with mr
biden and she is in edoboro scotland for
us this morning rija how are you
i'm gray tony i hope you guys are as
well president biden put climate change
at the front and center of his agenda on
day one when he rejoined that paris
agreement after his predecessor pulled
out of it but as this summit is
unfolding here in scotland lawmakers in
his own party continue to negotiate
legislation that includes more than half
a trillion dollars to help combat the
problem
they know me i know them we can get
things done together president biden
argued his personal relationships with
other world leaders allowed them to make
tangible progress at the g20 summit in
rome we passed a number of things here
to end
the uh
the subsidization of coal we made
commitments here from across the board
all of us in terms of what we're going
to bring to
the g26 but he said when it comes to
climate change the focus should be on
what countries like russia china and
saudi arabia are not doing not only
russia but china basically didn't show
up in terms of any commitments to deal
with climate change the leaders who
attended the summit pledged to work to
limit global warming but offered few
firm commitments secretary of state
anthony blinken insisted the talks were
a launching point for future work this
is not tomorrow's problem this is
today's problem president biden also
faced questions about his political
standing back home a new poll shows his
approval rating has declined by seven
points since august and 71 percent of
americans say the country is headed in
the wrong direction i didn't run to
determine how well i'm going to do in
the polls the president was hopeful that
both his build back better agenda and
infrastructure bill would pass in
congress by the end of next week
combined they have 900 billion dollars
in climate resistance
and dealing with
climate and resilience and
it's the largest investment in the
history of the world that's ever
occurred and it's going to pass but
progressives like vermont senator bernie
sanders won assurances that moderate
democrats namely arizona's kirsten
cinema and west virginia's joe manchin
are fully on board you don't have to
have all of the
legislative language but you have to
have a statement which says a b c d and
e is going to be in the package and 50
members of the senate are supporting it
white house press secretary jenn saki
who did not come on this trip with
president biden tested positive for kova
19 on sunday in a statement saki said
that she last saw president biden on
tuesday before the trip when they sat
outside more than six feet apart with
masks the white house says president
biden tested negative yesterday he is
scheduled to be here in scotland for the
next couple of days helping to put
together a global framework on climate
change and he plans to be back in
washington on wednesday nate
from global warming to his buildback
better plan he has his plate full that's
for sure ouija thank you